-Congrats on this cover.
You look gorgeous here.
-Thank you. Thanks.
-Beautiful.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-First time in Rio.
-Oh, is it Rio?
-Yeah.
-I almost said, "Where is it?"
-Yeah. Brazil, Rio.
-Did you have fun there?
-First time. I loved it so much.
It's a beach town,
so I feel like, whenever I can,
like, look out the window and
watch beach volleyball going on,
I'm happy.
-You love that, yeah.
-Did you do any escape rooms
in there?
-No, I do escape rooms
in a lot of towns that I go to.
-I see that.
-But not Rio. I didn't check.
-You didn't do that.
-I love escape rooms.
-Where else have you done
escape rooms?
-I've done one here.
I've done one in L.A.,
Santa Barbara.
-Are you good at these rooms?
-I love them.
I studied criminal psychology
in college.
I don't know
if I've told you that.
So, I'm really into, like,
all of that kind of --
kind of detective work
and mystery-solving.
All that kind of stuff.
I love it.
-You go in a room,
you have to solve a puzzle
to get to the next room, right?
-And it's, like, a great way
to, like, get, you know,
new friends in the group
or, like, whatever, just to go
do something together and fun.
-Are you fun when you do this?
Or are you intense?
Would you yell at me
if I was in a room with you?
-I'm, like -- I'm like,
super nice,
if you're, like, there
to win with me.
You know what I mean?
But, like, if you're,
like, goofing off,
no, I'm not nice about it.
-I don't know if
I would goof off so much.
Maybe, like, going in,
I would goof a little.
-No, we'll work as a team.
We'd be good.
We should go together one time.
-We should, yeah.
But what kind of things do you
see when you go into the rooms?
-Okay, so, like, every single
room is a different theme.
So it could be a murder mystery.
It could be that you're, like --
And you get a little story
before.
So, you could be, like,
stuck in a spaceship,
and you have an hour or 45
minutes to get out.
Or you could be --
There was one where, like,
your neighbor is a murderer
and you have to find out,
like, who he murdered.
But you're stuck in one room,
and all of the clues
are within the room.
You're given no clues
before that,
and you kind of just have to
figure a way out.
-Wow, fun!
-But there's all different,
like, themes.
You can them look up online
and, like, see what you're into.
-Good.
I would do that with you.
-Yeah.
-Let's talk about what you're
doing with Reebok.
Congrats on this thing.
-Thank you.
-"Reebok by Gigi Hadid."
-i just designed my first
collection for Reebok,
which is my first activewear
athleisure collection.
And I was a volleyball player
in high school.
-I didn't know that.
-Yeah.
And so, when I
moved to New York,
I kind of always was in, like --
when I was going to college,
I was always in workout clothes
and then trying to make those
into, like, kind of
a fashion look
so that I could go to school
and then go straight to the gym
afterwards.
And, like, that kind of became
this athleisure-style thing
that people always ask me about.
So when I did
my Reebok collection,
I really wanted it
to be something
where, if I was
a college student again,
I feel like I could wear this
to school
and feel, like,
great in it and cute.
But then also it's something
that you can wear to the gym
and work out, and
that's what it's made for.
So, a lot of --
Right now, the streetwear,
a lot of the time,
is not actually comfortable
to work out in,
which I think is weird.
-It just looks cool, yeah.
-Or, like, the dad shoes
that cost like $1,000 to look
like your dad's old sneakers,
and you, like, can't work out.
They're not good for your foot.
So, I don't get that.
-Yeah, yeah.
What the sense of that?
-So, yeah, this is style and --
-But you did something different
when you were launching this.
-Yeah, so, when I launched it,
my first idea was --
you know, when we sat down
and we wanted to come up
with a concept
for the collection,
I wanted my high school coaches
to come to New York
and do the press day with me,
because we have these press days
that a lot of the time
feel very unpersonal
and they're kind of, like,
strange to get through.
And I thought,
"What would I want to do
that I could be mostly myself
and be really inspired that day.
So I asked Reebok to fly
my high school coaches out.
We went to the
DREAM Charter School uptown
and played with the girls'
volleyball team.
And it was just so awesome and
a really nice way to launch it.
It made me so happy.
-This is Gigi with
the DREAM Charter School --
East Harlem volleyball team.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And this is you playing.
-Yeah, there's me.
-Were you good?
-I was pretty good, Jimmy.
You would have probably gotten
scared of me on the court.
Like, you know, guys would be
like, "Oh, yeah,
let's go watch Gigi
on the volleyball court."
By the end of the game,
they're like, "She's scary."
Like, "I don't think she's cute
anymore" kind of vibe.
-Really? You get right in there?
-Oh, yeah.
And, like, my coach, we'd
have to have some calm-downs.
Like, "You're not gonna be able
to start next game
if I see you punch the ground
once."
Like, I'd get mad and,
like, get really into it.
But I played high school
volleyball so intensely.
And club volleyball, I went to
Junior Olympic qualifiers.
And it's just something
that I think is so important
for young girls to
find that value in themselves
in other things, and
things that inspire them
or that they want to
get better at.
And that, for me, was volleyball
and horseback riding and art.
And I think
that having those things
that you know
that you're great at
and that you love
gives you the feeling
that you can take those
and have a future with them.
So it was really important
to me,
at the DREAM Charter School,
to just show girls
that, like, putting your mind
to something
and really wanting
to get good at it
can give you so much
of a bigger future.
And I think that's great,
whatever it is you want to do.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Good for you.
Congrats on that.
-Thank you.
-Now, every time -- every time
you come on the show,
we really end up getting in a
conversation about hamburgers.
-Yeah. We love burgers.
-We love burgers. We really do.
-And we think about each other
every time we eat burgers,
'cause we're always trying
to one-up each other
of who's going to find
the next best burger.
-I found it.
-Okay, go!
-I thought about you --
-Wait! Hold on.
I have something for you, too.
You get the burgers that way,
and I have something --
hold on -- over here
that I need.
-What are you doing?
-Okay, Jimmy --
-What are you getting?
-I brought us something
to eat burgers with.
Tiny hands.
[ Laughter ]
"What?"
-We're going to eat burgers
with tiny hands?
-Yeah.
-Why?
-'Cause I always bring you
something tiny.
I brought you your tiny bag
last time.
-Yeah, tiny bag.
I remember tiny bag.
-And, look, we can model
with them, too.
-It's actually not bad.
Yeah, okay.
All right, so, wait -- this is
from a place called Upland.
-Upland. Shout-out to Upland!
Thank you!
-Upland. It's on --
where is it? -- 26th and Park.
All right, get ready for this.
You're gonna freak out.
It's avocado --
-You got to
put your tiny hands on it.
-I know, I will. Sorry.
[ Laughter ]
All right, here we go.
Wait. It's hard
to hold the hamburger.
It's hard to -- Wait.
How are you doing it?
-Cheers. Like this.
-I know, but, gosh.
You got really strong
fingers, man.
-I'm a volleyball player.
Cheers.
-All right, here we go. Cheers.
You're the best, Gigi.
[ Light laughter ]
[ Soft jazz plays ]
-Wow!
-Right?
-Mm-hmm.
-It's pretty good, right?
-Avocado!
-Avocado in the house!
Gigi Hadid, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Her new line,
Reebok by Gigi Hadid,
is available now.